-White House Press Secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
hasn't been holding
many press briefings lately,
so we decided to hold one of our
own right here, right now.
That's right,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the Late Night Press Corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House Press Briefing.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Secretary Sanders!
Secretary Sanders.
Secre--
Yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders,
who do you think
you'll be working for
by this time next year?
-President Mike Pence.
-Oh.
-What's the rarest thing
in the entire universe?
-A question
that I could answer.
[ Laughter ]
-Where does Donald Trump
see himself in five years?
-Prison.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I heard -- Sarah...
I heard President Trump
burnt his hand pretty bad
the other day.
What did he burn it on?
-The Bible.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Name someone you'd
rather have dinner with
than Ivanka and Jared?
-Every single member of ISIS.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Secretary Sanders,
do you believe in Hell?
-That's where we are right now.
[ Audience "Oohs," laughter ]
-Okay, hypothetical.
Let's say Donald Trump
was exiting Air Force One
and his pants pocket
got caught on the railing,
causing him to trip,
which, in turn,
ripped his pants completely off
and jelly beans flew everywhere
as he tumbled
all the way down the stairs
in his tighty whiteys.
If that happened,
what would be the top story
that night on Fox News?
-Hillary Clinton.
[ Audience "Oohs," laughter ]
-I heard President Trump
is requesting
a ham this Thanksgiving.
Why is that?
-He's not happy with turkey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Let's get serious.
What does President Trump think
is the most romantic thing
to do on a first date?
-Sign an NDA.
[ Laughter ]
-What broke the chair
in the oval office?
-The full weight
of the government.
[ Laughter ]
-Sarah, some people say
you're not cool,
you're not hip.
I know that's not true.
So to prove
that you're cool and hip,
what is the name of the boy band
from the U.K.
that Harry Styles was in?
-The Wrong Direction.
[ Laughter ]
-How would Yoda --
Yoda from "Star Wars" --
describe the correspondence
between the White House
and North Korea?
-Responded to Chairman Kim's
letter the President has.
[ Laughter ]
-Guess what.
-Turkey butt.
[ Laughter ]
-Good one.
What does Melania
ask for at hotels
when traveling with Trump?
-Single room.
[ Laughter ]
-Roseanne Barr says she's
leaving her home in Hawaii
to go live
in Israel for a while.
What will this help?
-The well-being
of all Hawaiians.
[ Laughter ]
-What is the core mission
of the Hanes Corporation?
-To brief the American people.
[ Laughter ]
-Secretary Sanders,
I have a policy question.
Can vampires enter any home,
or do they have to wait
to be invited in?
-I would refer you
to Rudy Giuliani
for all questions
on that matter.
-Well, looks like we're
out of time, so on behalf
of the rest of the press corps,
have a great night.
We'll be right back
with Cynthia Nixon, everyone.